gender pronouns I said sir do you prefer
miss mamsi super masculine / feminine
madam you can ma'am I can use that with
you no not with me you don't a man and
before them an angel of social justice
warrior ism appeared and said behold I
bring you tidings of great gender
pronoun rules never assume someone's
gender or pronouns always ask don't
assume if you're unsure about somebody's
pronoun you pull them aside and ask you
know hey what are your pronouns we also
don't want to assume anyone's gender
identity your pronouns just be like hey
all right how are you what's your name
what's your pronoun hey what are your
pgps I've been doing it wrong this whole
time what is your problem you
insensitive oh I know I know so to
redeem myself I decided to follow these
rules exactly every day people don't
like me much yes sir have you have you
I'm sorry real quick I'm sorry I just
used sir what are your that was rude of
me what are your preferred gender
pronouns preferred what thank you very
much sir yeah I'm sorry that was rude of
me what are your preferred gender
pronouns I should have not said ma'am
what are your preferred gender pronouns
be Miss Z gender-neutral
sir okay from me ma'am gender-neutral z
question for Miss mamsi super masculine
/ feminine madam you can ma'am I can use
that with you no not with me you don't
have man what are your preferred gender
pronouns I said sir I assumed you could
be met ma'am sir no I want to get this
right I don't want to be offensive I'm
really sorry
should it be ma'am sir do you want to go
with gender neutral
gender neutral V
okay but you haven't answered hey I'm
problem actually I prefer gender-neutral
Z for pronouns well I don't know I don't
want to assume it's rude of me okay well
my boiler is the man and I have a wives
so I'm a man you may not know I was
trying to be that's actually a little
bit offensive we're just trying to make
sure that people are inherently where
the genders non-binary well female is
sex I'm talking about gender how do you
identify the ma'am she gender-neutral Z
I was trying to be polite I asked them
their preferred gender pronouns and they
laughed should I have said ma'am or
gender-neutral z you could be
transitioning this okay I'm assuming
your sir yes okay gender-neutral Z is is
I was in the military so is used to
being called served I know but I have
some people I know who are in transition
and they're it do you ask people before
for you to learn it's always more polite
to ask than assumed and that was my
mistake more polite to Aspen to a soon
Emperor how can I be a woman there can
be female Emperor's are you guys dude
into a while is ma'am okay for
gender-neutral notes
it's not funny have a my brothers in
transition so I want to make sure I'm
sensitive
pardon my french but you was more polite
to ask the proper gender pronouns
no it does matter these people have been
marginalized and we can't treat we can't
other them so however you how do you
identify Oh female is sex I'm talking
about gender how do you identify
you know this isn't gonna work Oh major
do you identify as a male female
genderqueer
oh forget it
you know what major are you a gender
studies okay you're never gonna
understand thank you no no no no no no
you told I know some real-life Dragon
Ball Z characters never learn speaking
of learning my favorite way to do so is
with audibles audiobooks audible.com
slash Crowder this month there's a promo
you can go there support the show and
try it for free who wants to read when
you can listen to an audiobook you're
watching youtube you're not reading so
watch YouTube and learn something at the
same time audible.com slash Crowder
support the show it is a great product
as far as books I recommend I always
recommend Andrew Clavin because firing
close hey youtube LGBTQ AI and the
pansexual community I don't know how we
fit you in the acronym yet I wouldn't
want to put you too far ahead or too far
behind because I know positional
hierarchy is very important in your
sexual movement either way please
subscribe to this channel because lots
of freak shows subscribed just like you
or you can watch one of these other
videos for free you might be offended
and we don't care